[Music]
so what's in it for me well I mean
absolutely fill it with great amount of
time talking about what what's becoming
what is DevOps so to speak so hopefully
you understand that we're going to
provide you an understanding with DevOps
is as well as provide you with
understanding other technical challenges
that are in DevOps and then how to
choose the best tools to help with those
technical challenges another part is how
to choose when to deploy applications
into the cloud right there's a movie
that that kind of quoted a no one knows
what the cloud is who knows the cloud is
right and it feels kind of you know it's
a very overused term
and we're going to provide some clarity
on that overuse and the different
components of that additionally we're
going to talk about you know different
security issues and then how to identify
the differences between requirements and
architecture and then how do you write
user acceptance
story so I'm going to walk through this
whole gamut of things that are going
from you and better provide you with the
ability to do DevOps when you go back to
your your jobs so they're nicely short
for the development operations so if you
look right over here right in this
diagram okay this is where we're
focusing on for a minute right so DevOps
is the combination of software
engineering quality assurance and
operations if you would it's where those
things intersect all right so where does
development intersect with operations
well the answer is easily when one of
these entities pcs when we deploy our
application from development to
operations for use that's one place that
development work intersects operations
right but as a part of that we also
understand that you know providing the
same type of type of context of the
developer for application development is
is very important right so that's
another place of intersection for
development operations or Quality
Assurance right is really just that in
order to provide consistency in
production level code that that's where
it interacts with development and
operations right ensuring that your
perhaps that your documentation is up to
par for these applications again could
be another place that QA Quality
Assurance meets up with them up as well
so DevOps are these are these people
that kind of work and operate in these
different areas now again I told you
earlier that sometimes we have skills
that transfer from development from
Quality Assurance and operations and
they transfer to a new context of
develop
operations right so each one of you have
a background that it's kind of more
focused on probably more than likely one
of the three if not it's still okay but
your context in your skill set is based
upon these three three areas but we're
DevOps this is where they all three meet
when your skills are important right so
demo it focuses on the level of
collaboration I cannot over stress this
enough your ability to collaborate with
the developers with those who control
operations those who maintain the
software and hardware and those who
coordinate with the building always
building stuff staff or logistics is so
important so let me give you a perfect
example so why do you need to
collaborate with people in the building
well so you get the building maintenance
people right and often they control the
power to the building so if they're
going through some routine maintenance
where there where the that's going to
require the power to be shut off and
maybe you have backups that automatic
switch over sometimes you don't well in
that case it would become imperative to
be able to community have a level of
communication with the building staff
building maintenance folks so that you
can ensure that your operation your
power stayed make this is available but
when you switch but sometimes quite
often even if you do some time when they
make the switch things fail so this not
understanding that that they're
performing some maintenance on the
electric panel or alone generators and
so forth is very critical to you not
only for that reason but sometimes you
have some requirements that are in place
that requires by law requires by your
your extended of operations that a
backup be in place and the backup being
shut down for operate
violates that policy right so it's
important that you you have a you're
able to collaborate with the building
staff additionally when deploying right
just simply getting an application from
from the development over to operations
right that's a challenge so whenever
that happens they have there has to be
some level of collaboration some level
communication between those who are
deploying the application and to those
who have develop it I am acutely aware
that just because you're deployed it
doesn't always mean that it works right
so sometimes you know it's good that you
know the way that you want to say this
to it's important that your teams are
set up in a way that fosters the best
level of communication okay i'ma say
that won't talk as important point to
make it's important that the your teams
are set up in a way that fosters the
best level of communications right I
would probably tell you that it's good
to avoid silos much as possible what I
mean by that is that sometimes you have
the people who implement DevOps is what
they'll do sometimes they'll say hey
let's have a development team let's have
a QA team let's have an Operations team
well I get with your dev ops team excuse
me well doing that is great in that you
kind of you know putting all the give up
to one place but the problem with that
is that you still create these silos
where the developers are separate from
DevOps and DevOps separate from
everything else so in my experience this
is stripping my experience it has proven
more successful when the dev ops are
integrated directly on the various
project teams so because that could very
strong means that is one way to do it
but it moves beyond just those from
meetings right there are some
decision different choices that you make
in the development of a product that
could include or exclude certain people
than it should and that's dangerous
right from under from maintaining your
flexibility maintaining your scalability
and maintaining reliability standpoint
it's important that as these tools are
developed but not developed in the dark
it's in that in you know in scrum
meetings they had their very pointed and
very short but what they do what they do
well is they uncover points of
collaboration so I would say that having
a data scrum meeting is the start of
something but it needs to go beyond that
all right so well the logic you ask
question do we use any tools to get the
feedback the answer is yes there could
be local ways to do that
gerrae is a fantastic way of identifying
this design that's design decisions and
then requesting that certain operations
staff comment on that code as well but I
will say this though if you're an
organization starting out that still
becomes a little difficult to do quite
honestly it becomes hard to do to
quote-unquote just use use tools per se
Valachi so we can and there's tools like
JIRA like I said that are available that
allows for collaborative and feedback
from design decisions also they're often
there's like messaging tools like slack
so life is a great tool to kind of have
a room dedicated to just that talking to
each other right so tools like the
messaging apps and great ways to provide
feedback as well as communicate with
your customer as well but I found that
when you're first starting out is those
implementing those tools it takes time
to get them to see for you to get to a
level maturity that allows you to kind
of
that flawlessly so sometimes it a lot
it's better to just kind of or it do a
thing but it is also good to have
face-to-face time to communicate so
balázs another question Jared we can
collect using issues or service tests
absolutely you can't so Atlassian very
specifically while there's other options
out there to sort of me wrong I am most
familiar personally with the Alaskan
toolset Atlassian products they have a
service desk and they have JIRA that are
separate implementations but yes you can
use those to presume not only identify
issues but also provide feedback for
what works and what doesn't work so not
a problem alright so one last question
with that said can i elaborate more on
this previous point about daily scrum
meetings so again I'll be Davis Cummings
again these daily scrum meeting so we
have existent in a scrum meeting is
everyone gets together and by the nature
of these four meetings the goal is to
identify blockers to identify what you
are doing for the day or for the next
two days put on your frequency of scrum
meetings but also to identify your
blockers right so the goal is to make
the team aware of the things that are
directly prohibiting you from continuing
to do your job or to do it effectively
what that does it provides owners with
the ability to help you resolve your
problems or if revise an opportunity for
others to help resolve your problem as
well but again the hard part about this
stuff is that sometimes we don't know
what we don't know so just simply saying
you have a problem may not always be
sufficient
it's what I'm saying so while these
these grunt daily scrum meetings can be
good to kind of identify surface level
things what I found to be a little bit
more
active is just kind of being able to
talk with the appropriate people about I
having regular scheduled meetings with
could be like production meetings it
could be code review it could be design
decisions review it could be a few other
things I found those kind of
face-to-face meetings a little bit more
valuable for me and getting feedback
from not only my development team but
also the the people that are responsible
for deploying the applications hey why
you didn't consider this security issue
that we're having and because of that we
need you to use this library versus DAP
because there's a fix we're doing ABCDEF
q and that was a practical problem that
I ran into when having that so the point
being is again you it's important that
we provide feedback loops and that we
increase our ability to collaborate with
these other of people in order for us to
the organization's the best produce a
methodology and an application that does
what it says we will do all right is
that actually a question we test all
right great
all right all right so them up so it's
focus on collaboration between the
developers of other parties right so we
talked about that about building
deploying and operating that's kind of
where I was and then just sort of
maintaining the software so let me give
you an issue that we ran into so and
maybe you all can understand this so we
there's a product that we developed over
15 years in that 15 years of product
development there's been hundreds of
developers that have added some
mechanism to that codebase all right so
here's what happens when you do that
excuse me what happens is that you begin
to give what we call spaghetti home
write code that kind of refers to a
bunch of other stuff and sometimes it's
a lot less efficient right and then on
top of that it's poorly commented code
which drives me crazy right so um what
happens is is that if developers look
for their own devices and they'll be
being the developer I think I could say
this you know we don't like documenting
as a as a rule of form although it's not
always true and as a rule of thumb we
just kind of really want to solve the
problem
and sometimes some of the problem isn't
always the most efficient way so I'm
saying all that because I'm stressing
the point of collaboration right so how
do we maintain our software in a way
that allows for DevOps staff to I
address and identify certain problems
that we that we have which is with the
deployments and a lot of that is by
focusing on implementing non spaghetti
code right that I talked about but
implementing a standardized code amounts
are it could be easily read oh singh on
readability over complexity focusing on
readability over complexity and the
other thing i want to point out is also
building documentation in such a way
that allows people to understand why
certain interfaces or cold products are
used versus others right so all of this
ties together so not only do we have to
collaborate between people that maintain
the building deployment operator but
just in developing and maintaining our
software applications is critical and
the way that we do that is by putting
our putting the code in such a way that
focuses on readability of the code and
use the DevOps ability to give them some
insight into how that code works or or
want okay so very very important point
DevOps is also it is about defining a
flow right how are you gonna go from
development to production hopefully
that's the goal but how you're going to
do it in a way that maintains a high
quality how you going to do it in a way
that allows consistent results
right so when you do it the goal is to
put in processes to put in checks and
balances and test that allows you to
consistently perform a certain task so
and the rule of thumb where there
inconsistency
there's problems if you will the
inconsistent smoke so to speak and they
say where there's smoke various fire
so whenever you begin to see
inconsistent things happening that's an
indication that you have a problem all
right so you got to define how you're
going to move from development over to
full-scale operations it is them I feel
also about systems thinking with
feedback I think we kind of talked about
that a little bit but but that's Justin
staging and feedback
the goal is provide that a little
further up front so that you can kind of
work through those issues all right
again the goal is include you have to
note everything in order to implement it
but the goal is to kind of make it in
small enough chunks that allows you to
close a loop or quickly fail and then
provide feedback for each issue resolved
right and then the emphasis is also on
automating processes right required to
release to release in change software
right so again software is always
changing there's always patches there's
always something but you have to be able
to consistently and once there's
consistently be able to consistently and
rapidly release these changes that
happen at a certain rate right so so
import so this would give up this then
is this way of thinking about problems
in a way that allows you to identify
problems fix them and get and make the
fixes and do that in a very efficient
input matter all right
and quickness and analysis is part two
little things work mission often looking
to say quick they say oh that's bad
because quick means is it is also
associated with not fully thought-out
and that's not always the case all right
what does condemn up issues
then on issues some requests in the
requirement for system right so here's
the thing being able to deal with these
requests
and deal with the requirements for a
system whether they're new or whether
they just kind of change existing
requirements is a key concept right so
here's what often happens and I think
anyone can relate to this I've been only
a software tool and I often work with
proprietary organizations or with
organizations that have to buy a carry
tools so for this particular proprietary
tool that I was working on
our goal was to simply for you to be
able to enter in a a word and find just
a simple query and just we started out
as just simply being able to search some
dot some documents and find the
documents where this word appears that
was our goal okay very simple this is
many many years ago and so Ruth you know
we were able to do that but then what
happens is that any tool that achieves
success once you achieve success guess
what
more requests come in
um so I see a question if it enough
thought work but then I get to your
question Balaji
so more requests come it comes in once
the requests come in they begin to
change the scope of your original
tasking or it adds various sub tasks or
you need to now to complete that still
within scope but provide additional
capability to your software well that's
a good thing but the question is how do
you begin to deal with those changes and
how do you manage change and this is
what DevOps do what we practically what
you can see is like in scrum meetings
particularly try to design this define
who's gonna work on what for your
current cycle your current sprint cycle
which is a way that adds often agile
methodology they kind of so work in a
particular sprint cycle a cycle where
people work on a particular task and by
the end of those two weeks or by the end
of that week whatever that the lift that
cycle is that work should be done all
right that's what a sprint cycle is so
what they do is that by the end of this
sprint cycle this work has to be
completed and and those changes added to
add a full release at whatever period
you decided upon so how do you deal with
those changes right and so then Ops is
definitely about that right now back to
the logics questions what a software
distribution means so for the software
distribution simply what I mean when I
say distribution I'm referring to
probably I should probably better say
Lippman correct distribution a software
deployment it's probably better word
right this this notion of just kind of
getting software from production over to
operations I am deploying the software
to production so so so here's what
happens like so developers develop code
and they write if your does they write
they have a source program or source
file and that code met class in Java
this is often called or that Java file
or that C file which are languages to
program in they take that file or series
of files that are somehow connected they
take those and they packages they
package them up in some file format that
file format could be something called a
jar file it could be a war file for
other applications it could be a variety
of things and they take that package of
files and they deploy them where they
move them to an operational environment
where that when they run they run with a
certain intent based upon application so
when I talk to my deployment what I'm
talking about is taking that code that
developers wrote and then packaging it
up and then moving it to a production
environment
to the nature of the logic
let me ask you a question
all right great all right so um so depth
uh-oh
so we'd ask them a very good question
she said how much important is on
documentation DevOps I would say it's
critical right because
it's critical several levels okay it's
critical from a end user standpoint so
if you would there's some documentation
that you write and often what I found is
that you can users use a particular
application that they don't have great
documentation that means that that's
often that's the biggest reason why
people cannot use your application and
they generate tickets for easily
solvable problems
so documentation from that standpoint I
think we all can relate to that just
simply using anything whether it's email
whether it's this or that you know
documentation is a key for you
understanding how to use it but then
from a from a from a strictly DevOps
perspective ie the the notion of going
between develop developers and quality
assurance stat and operations how-to
documentation that want outlines all of
the processes that you use it's going to
be key to helping every to help you put
everyone on the same page so you got
DevOps from a processing standpoint that
documentation needs to need to kind of
be clear and often what we use on our
job to do that is you primarily operated
with Atlassian products and so
confluence is a great tool to do that
now comes at a cost but nonetheless it's
a tool that kind of allows everyone it's
a Wikipedia type tool that allows
everyone to kind of chime in and to
create these pages of information that
talks about the process so I found from
developer to developer from operational
operations
almost all of us go to confluence this
Wikipedia type tool and we in order in
order to understand how you know
something is configured how it works
that I often that's my first stop is
that confluence tool so having that kind
of documentation is extremely critical
all right all right
um yoky asked me get out are we dating -
let me show you a book tag so again um
this I'm going to bring this up
I'm going to state that in this work
with and go to the Alaskan product hours
firm to again I'm not there's other
tools out there and it really is and
there are many other okay
this is the Atlassian tool and they have
several products to include any of those
and I believe there was a question about
Trello so but per potentially Trello is
to legislate the slack is more
message-based Smitha
right so but nonetheless what I'm going
to point out is that you have zero
software and service desks but this tool
called confluence right and confluence
is it looks very similar to what we have
here or hopefully see my mouse are right
here this page right over in this area
this is a comp law if you have these
these uh menu app icon up here but
allows you to kind of design whatever it
is you need and it's just a great tool
and then the nice thing about it is that
they have various plugins that have
different functionality right so it's
just again I think it's just overall
it's a really good tool that helps you
kind of manage corporate information so
what I'm going to do I'll put the link
in the message box so they know in your
spare time you can go look at it if you
want to this is another example of a
tool that will allow you to kind of one
collaborate and put down in place the
kind of documents information as a whole
and I will say without a tool like this
capturing corporate knowledge is very
very difficult
submit I ask another question so is it
like ads on medical - I would probably
say confluence in and of itself is
probably not but for the Gero Gero is
definitely helped with the management of
them at the agile process
and they got several tools in here that
allows you to work with that as well
so Jerome asked a question if you
implement DevOps does it mean that the
traditional IT ops team should now act
to function as DevOps uh is what I'll
say I wouldn't
kind of say absolutely that's the way to
go what I think it depends upon is the
skillset of your date of your operations
team we said earlier if we go back into
the slide we said earlier DevOps is a
way to kind of is the intersection where
these three areas meet so if your
operations team only have a network
skill if you would then maybe they're
not quite the team to work through up
quite honestly in my experience and what
I found is that the people that are more
likely to have the skills to work in the
DevOps tend to be software developers
like if I were if I were to start with a
team and if I were to kind of just
simply say you'll be my DevOps team
again it would be difficult but I do
think that generally as a rule of thumb
software developers because of their
need to interact with a lot of different
levels often although this is always
true often serve as the first stop to go
now I will say this too sometimes your
DevOps team they have a different spin
on things right your your DevOps team
maybe best need to deal with primarily
release management maybe that's kind of
where you reach your main sticking point
well if that's the case then maybe the
operations team might be better suited
to deal with releasing and things of
that nature so there isn't a standard
per se but
really kind of depend upon your your use
patient really what is your primary
focus right now based upon whatever gaps
you have another demo issues include
some were designed to don't let testing
release the next step on the path and we
kind of hammered that home and so
hopefully you understand that this flow
is very critical
additionally bill out issues include how
you going to package and distribute and
deploy your software
right so I mean ultimately that's kind
of that's a DevOps problem and so we're
testing yet they asked the question so
tool be used based on the requirement
skill set and integral I would say yes
ritesh
um and that's that's an important point
because again our we can't very really
can we save in the devops world one shoe
fits everyone it's important that you
take a measured approach and
understanding that I had these areas to
consider and there are several tools
within each area that I need to identify
so yes so you want to get your
requirements the skill sets of staff you
have and the infrastructure determine
what works best so uh Smit ask another
question that's far additional concern
we look at it from the other perspective
does it mean more wider basically I'm
like well distribution which could be
automated automated uh I think it could
be I think quite honestly if I was just
starting out I would take it in smaller
chunks with with scripting and just kind
of moving things because it well I think
other factors that may include things
like your architecture right how many
time how much software how many nodes
you have to lose your deployed with -
that's that's definitely a factor are
you moving it from your private
infrastructure to AWS Amazon Web
Services which is a cloud provider or
are you moving it to Google cloud which
is another cloud provider so I would say
that deciding which tools to use I think
you would have to consider as far as
automation is where are you moving it
from and what if in what are you moving
it to
those kind of things are going to be
critical in answering so that you can
identify what tools are best suited for
me and automating what I need to
automate
okay all right um excellent all right so
uh software packaging distribution I'm
on a third bullet down their software
packaging and distribution of deployment
again that is a because what I'm doing
is defining the scope of the DevOps
problem all right that's what I'm doing
so how to pack your software distributed
and deploy our major things now all
ongoing software operations or running
the system right so this notion of being
able to just simply operate it and
monitor it right how are you going to
monitor your system to include the
hardware the application and anything
else you have running on your machine
and identifying problems this is a big
big issue practically what we're finding
at the end where I work often we're
having to probably just recently we
change this but before we would have to
have three or four different monitoring
tools to monitor the hardware the
software the deployed application and so
forth and it was just problematic like
with tools which tool that I go to again
what I want to see this
that's all you know when you got 20
tools and they all do similar things if
you know that is a problem within itself
and it also adds a great level of
overhead to what it is what it is you're
trying to do so
Balaji asked a question they said uh
migrating to cloud related issues also
should be part of DevOps
issues another I think that's a very
very good point you're right the fact
that you're migrating it has to be
included as part of the DevOps
absolutely
because really that migration is going
to be conducted by the dev ops staff
also that migration so I would say comes
under this third bullet here balaji
software packaging distribution
employment right there and i feel coming
there and then maybe even a part of part
two as well because the software
developers have to develop with the the
fact that it's going to the cloud in
their mindset so often each cloud
provider provides a variety of tools
that are accessible to the developer
right and so understanding that it's
going to affect their all right Thank
You Balaji is going to affect their
ability to deploy it okay all right
deployment issues
so deployment issues again our Vic that
notion of taking an application a
package of code and moving it from the
development system to production
that's deployment so when deploying code
or deploying the application you're
going to there could be filled gaps that
exist that may have been hidden right
because I told you before sometimes you
don't know what you don't know so the
deployment of these applications these
web application the enterprise average
the service it requires people that have
these special skill sets
he DevOps right additionally the
developers that write the code write the
application code or the software code
they often have little knowledge of the
actual server itself and that is a very
free statement well I may be a good
coder doesn't necessarily give me
instant understanding of all the
different nuances of operating an
application server right I love green
add all this have you heard about DevOps
operation team's install and manage the
application server right so and those
people are usually not the developers
all right these are some of the
deployment issues that we run into
and then lastly what happens when the
application is deployed into the server
right so when that that point you're
going to need people who are both
developers in operation to resolve any
issues this is why I said that in my
experience is often better that be for
each project team that there are DevOps
developers kind of working together to
accomplish their goals versus doing it
the other way where you just kind of
create a DevOps team if they they're
responsible for all the DevOps stuff
because they often don't when it's done
that way they often don't have the
perspective necessary to work through
projects for cific issues
alright alright so let's talk about this
demo tool chain this is I'm asking a
little time talking about this alright
this is a diagram of the plane for
qubits in the previous slide okay but I
just wanted to be able to provide you
with a few other things I'm let's get
out of this sweet [ __ ] okay so um in
this category of tools you know this
this is providing apply the template you
should have something that monitors
application performance and hardware
components you should have tools that
allow you to release into production you
should have tools that allow you to deal
with configuration management you should
have ways of ensuring accurate good code
development and unit testing you should
have tools that build applications right
sometimes application comes from
multiple source files and so on having a
tool that knows where to go to get
everything is really important and then
you need to be able to form integration
and performance testing right Timothy
lastly just simply packaging the
application so there's a concept called
continuous integration and continuous
deployment it's this notion that ask
code makes it in as the changes are
submitted for approval and they are
approved that code is automatically
tested and integrated with the bid is
integrated with the application all
right so so we have a couple questions
where does regression testing fit into
this I think regression testing can be
done either it can be done in several
places probably my first stop might be
when building the application yes
exactly
yeah exactly yogi between building and
immigrating right right between these
two okay and then the lobby ask can we
give examples of two or three stuff
exactly why I did it this way the
lodging so will I'm too getting to that
okay
so monitoring and let's start with
monitoring and performance okay so when
monitoring you have to be able to
monitor both the application
the framework and/or the hardware
okay so the application itself ie the
code that you created your hardware
and/or framework so what is what I mean
my framework like Hadoop is a framework
that allows you to perform certain
functions that your code may accomplish
right so your code can use Hadoop it can
use MapReduce it can use these other
tools to perform a certain function
right so you not only need need to
monitor your application that's using
the framework but you also need to
monitor that the brain work itself that
it's using and then that framework is
installed on several servers so if you
were to look at it from a perspective
this is probably the perspective to look
at it from okay so
so this may be your your architecture
right here using your service is that
your application is running on okay so
all this only all these set of servers
Memphis cookies look further over here
on this set of service and let's just go
server one server to and server 3 all
this set of applicable to the server's
yet the month of these service but then
you may have an app you may have a
framework we have the Hadoop
each Hadoop file data file system we
have this right and that HDFS as call is
deployed across multiple service so not
only do you need to monitor the servers
but you also need to monitor your
framework and then what you might have
excuse me you may have
another set of servers
and let's just call the server for
excuse me server server for and server
pipe and you may have this and this is
where your application resides
right this is where this is this is
where it's on and then what happens is
is that new
you
you need to be able to kind of talk to
both of those right from the application
to better court to the hdfs so what's
going to happen is that you're going to
monitor
all of the hardware to check out your IO
but then you got to monitor your your
your framework to include HDFS and a lot
of times these frameworks have their own
monitoring tools and then you're going
to have to monitor your application now
the crazy thing about it is though might
be three separate monitoring tools Diego
from monitor one - two - two - two three
- see how all of these things are going
on right so there are some tools that
are better at doing that now we can't
get into all the specifics I just want
to kind of show you that there's some
tools that are out there okay so one of
the tools that can be used to do that is
not not yield or mmm oh yeah so one of
the tools that are often used no matter
where you go is not yelps all right and
what we can't get into the system out it
but I will say knock Yeltsin is the
Nagios core is an open source tool that
allows you to download with limited
capability right and but a lot of time
with these services in order for you to
get other things they have other paid
products you can use to increase your
capability okay so and then probably the
other thing that's worth noting there
are like thousands of Nagios plugins be
used with Nagios so that's the power of
Nagios because there's a big community
behind
Nagios that will often simply share
their plugins that they have developed
and written all right but at the core
it's kind of made to kind of monitor
your your art your architecture and if
you would oh s related type things okay
so that's not real now another one that
is probably worth mentioning is
and you may have heard of it is elastic
search okay look I mean
I'm going to put these tools in the chat
box so if you want to go back to them
you can okay so another one is probably
we're looking at is elasticsearch now
again now things like this require a
little bit more development to really
kind of make it work and affect it but
nonetheless it's a great tool and this
is the one that I built personally and I
like it better than Nagios because it's
easier to integrate
the the application monitoring the
framework monitoring and the hardware
monitoring is a part of that it is a lot
easier to me and then from there you can
then begin to build analytics that kind
of run to determine how these low you
know when something breaks identify when
it breaks so that you take action right
probably one of the main issues with
HDFS is input/output right you're
building to read and write
so as HDFS writes to disk sometimes you
have these disk bottlenecks excusing
where it's not writing fast enough or
whether it's not really fast enough so
um yo TAS how do we define framework
when it comes to multiple technologies
in our applications involved like B
application mainframe um so yeah back in
so here's what I would say often when I
think of frameworks I don't necessarily
think about the middleware portion quite
honestly or even Java for that matter
right typically when I think of
frameworks
I think of frameworks that allow you to
perform some functionality or most parts
like some database framework there was
across its distributed so if you will
you may have a piece that one will
server once over to two or three to five
and together they work to accomplish a
particular in a particular something I
think of that as a framework when it
comes to XML job applications and
mainframe etc all those can can be used
to implement a particular framework
right so I don't necessarily consider
those things as the framework I think
frameworks are probably a distraction
above what you just mentioned
so obviously that Schmitt I asked the
question can obvious be used on Windows
I think the answer is yes although I'm
not 107 positive about that one yeah I
think so yeah
yeah it is now what I don't know is it
they charge for that one I'm not sure
about that let's buy some people look
into
alright our move on alright and that
research so elasticsearch is its in
itself there really is a like an index
database tool it takes data index little
center center right but the cool thing
about some of the things that you have
available muscular is these products so
the Lexus elasticsearch is the core of
the product but you also have Kabana and
what obama is is that it's a
visualization tool that's very similar
so to ask but I can question Vince
Miller
so Jim Cabana is a visualization tool
that allows him to do a lot of different
things whether it's kind of makes a good
query can create analytics and it
interested really just a nice great tool
it also does time series data which you
know logs are time series related right
you can do graph relationships all kind
of coolness with Kabam so come on if you
would is the visualization tool that the
developer to use to get insight to their
architecture now with that being said
unless your search is what with index
the data ok now this tool called beats
beats uh these these things a lot of
these are free now beats provide these
different would be different packages
they call them beep they apply the
packages across different types packages
these factors do different things right
so what you can do is I can take these
different beats and apply them on a
particular server and then those beats
will grab what it makes they have and
send them to a central elasticsearch
repository
right so let's just look at this the
beach family so I can look at log files
with bowel beat and these log files are
often was you know different framework
security things they use those log files
to record what something's going on and
you can send those at with with low
latency to and election search database
additionally there's other various
metric you can measure for there's
Network data you can look at that's
window.event logs as well as your uptime
as well all of these things can be used
and centrally viewed and coordinated
with in elasticsearch this is why I
personally this is why I prefer this
tool because it's open source number one
and I don't have to pay a cost to really
kind of build these things outside of
just developer time
so it is recommended for much data into
the application like e-commerce domains
for example well so I I wouldn't be
careful with this because elasticsearch
it works really well like we have a lot
of notes like you know thousands of
thousands of notes and there are all
kind of a slow execution of something
going on in a shtetl all the time and it
works fine but elasticsearch itself at
some point as far as it isn't still up
to like a petabyte scale right so the
answer is that as far as your data into
the applications i this it has the data
application application itself doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
less and search with less as far as the
context in which I'm speaking about left
to search it left the surface just
simply grab whatever law whatever
performance criteria you you're putting
out and moves it over to election search
or process but it's a whole different
conversation if we want to run those
data into the applications all of you
left to search all right all right so
again
so again those just a few about the
monitoring performance other things they
include releasing it for into production
so the next monitoring performance we've
taken care of that piece now who wants
of leaking into production and I got to
kind of try to hurry up a little bit now
moving into production there's several
tools that you can use for that one of
them I would probably recommend and
together the things I recommend are
primarily open source like that until
ansible is a great tool and there's
another one called salt stack
both of these are similar tools you may
find heard the most popular just to kind
of put it out there yes yes the actually
shaft above it yet exactly these are
these are some of the tools again
without getting into the specifics you
know okay and it is this quite a quite a
few tools tools out there they are
similar they're simple they are similar
similarly kind of built in a goal is to
kind of move along this line of little
taking this this this code and once it
happened is built deploying it into
production and it's like several other
one-off type things you can use as well
these are some of the more popular ones
doesn't mean it's always the best but
it's one of the more popular ones that
these tools do a great job of not only
releasing into production but also
automating a lot of your tasks to
include configuration management right
so if you would the two on the left hand
side listen to production configuration
management those other great tools be
used in order to do that okay now for I
think probably one of the the top tools
they use for building and packaging is a
tool called Jenkins I'm sure many of you
have heard of that again another
open-source tool they have a paid
version for this but they have thousands
of plugins as well as well as the arts
community this this tool can be used to
automate the integration and excuse me
who is head of way for building
applications in integrated performance
if you would this is what we talked
about earlier these two building
applications and integration of
performance testing Jenkins provides
pipelines allow you to do that to ensure
continuous integration and continuous
delivery and there's other tools like
Jenkins one that begins with an H that
I'm kind of drawing a blank on I'll
think about it here in a minute and I'll
provide it to you but a number tools
like pink is out there and they are open
source for could code development in
unit testing the unit testing runs well
with women with Dinkins but you have to
write the test first right so the
developers have to definitely understand
the unit testing library and the unit
testing mechanism Nords to properly
write the test like I personally have
moved from unit testing where I was
using J unit for Java unit testing and
now they kind of have this they move to
a format that allows you to create
answer files for your testing not so
let's just simply about testing each
function the point of functionality but
it's not more about really truly
measuring the output of your code and
what that needs to ensure that a
something is working so Pilate asked a
question can puppet itself be installed
on Mac machines I'm not sure bellotti
quite honest with I just never really
had to do that so I just I'm not sure I
know salt and Asheville can but most
certainly can be because the whole point
of them is to be OS agnostic but I'll
put that out to the class if you want
have to deploy a puppet or chef on Macs
before
no okay yeah so but I think the answer
is yes but I will have to verify that so
I'll put it down as one of my questions
to answer
so another question Jerome they asked
the question
Thank You Schmidt Ursula can go on that
excellent
do I have tools that you recommend for
CIC be for dotnet windows and javelins
shot dumb
well a lot of questions excellent so the
question is do we have tools that you
recommend for CI containers integrations
material development for tight net
windows and java Linux so I know Jenkins
is a great tool continuous integration
axioms development correction excuse
liver excuse me or Java for dot what my
experiences is is Linux quite honestly
that's not so much as on the window side
but I I'm almost certain that Jenkins
can also run on Windows as well yeah
thank you
so does but dotnet
so um so spirits talk about it windows
if you already have it around
TFS then you might think of that
excellent okay all right another one
they did to talk about was team City
right that's a tell us J if I recall
correctly right till the hour jetbrains
Oh
mmm listen yeah so did ring the big room
team city and it works with King and
Grayson out the box but not necessarily
contains delivery but it might be
worthwhile I mean there many options out
there everyone again I'm just kind of
putting a few of them out there so that
you kind of know where to go to help
find some of those okay all right
oh where am i all right
um packing the application of what
in super deep he also missed something
too as well I assume you
people electric are you translating
electric ah thank you sorry the [ __ ] off
okay
so I prefer deep recommended perhaps
electric cloud for seamless delivery so
that I'm a part of that but that's a spy
something worth looking into
alright alright lastly um code
development in unit testing so but coal
development I would recommend like
probably the most common thing that
almost every developer teen uses thank
you for deeper that for that URL
appreciate that
probably one of the main ones well I've
hit my time
it's github.com
um github provides enterprise level
support for you and there's other tools
that go along with github for for
packaging up your software and version
control github and then there's another
one an Atlantian product call this not
bitmoji I'm sorry
yes thanks so yeah it's tough work so
they got big Huskies was talking about
yeah big bucket stash was the previous
one velocity that they used but this
bucket is kind of the latest version of
that and so they had available for you
as well and stash the older version of
this bucket all right um I think I've
hit my limited one so I got it so as you
can see there are a large variety of
tools that we can use to excuse me
a large variety of tools that we can use
to to work through everything hopefully
so from the ashes getting up an editor
like Eclipse Sunday github is is not an
IDE like eclipse or the integrated
development environment it is not github
just kind of keep track of versions and
it allows you to immigrate code it like
to control what is able to be placed in
a release
all right control of the datum so you
air Mike Smith they're cold and then you
can say I want this code this code this
code to be included as a part of this
relief
to work through it
all right so uh
Thank You Bilotti that's great way to
give away but it's very controlled to
with the metas code of the developers at
one location or even multiple locations
so excellent
I left me with dimension Sanjay the butt
however you probably right so I saw a
question here they talked about it also
the book wishing
okay it's a Schmidt a - this trick time
TC ask a question it's a tool open
source where control AMC and integrate I
think that alright so I think this will
conclude our session for today again
hopefully you found this session useful
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here